a huge leap forward in the Athletics
moving to Las Vegas Governor Lombardo
signing the a stadium bill into law
today after it passed through a special
session in the legislature this week as
we've reported that 1.5 billion dollar
Stadium will be on the Strip at the
current site of the Tropicana
Breaking News Sasha Loft has heard from
fans with ties to Las Vegas and to
Oakland who can't wait until that first
pitch is thrown
one step
to playing Major League Baseball in Las
Vegas I'm excited I'm pumped up come on
bring them over Baseball fans sharing
their excitement over the latest hurdle
crossed by the Athletics in their quest
to make a new home in the valley
everybody kept saying that it was not
going to pass but uh
he pushed it through Governor Joe
Lombardo signed the a stadium funding
bill into law Thursday after it passed
through a special session in the
legislature this week it gives the team
380 million dollars of Public Funding
for the 1.5 billion dollar Stadium at
the current site of the Tropicana The
Next Step goes to MLB owners for
relocation Vote many say they're looking
forward to the economic benefits another
protein could bring I think our host
values property go up and it'll be good
for the town just like the golden
knights While others can't wait for a
new entertainment opportunity and
actually more an aviators fan than an
A's fan but I will come to the A's games
just because they're here in our city
that's quickly becoming an ever-growing
Sports Mecca forget about Oakland
it's been great but see ya